hello everyone and welcome to champions
showdown enter the match everyone's been
waiting for after 16 years
of their previous encounter in reykjavik
gary kasparov faces magnus carlsen
uh in chess 960 and magnus carlsen gets
yet
another chance to uh to well take
another crack at the former world
champion gary kasparov
and it's uh well it's a it's a really
interesting game but
one of the things i didn't enjoy about
this game is that the randomization of
the pieces
uh didn't become all that random as you
can see the rooks are on the exact same
places as they are in the regular chess
as
also the knights uh and uh once the game
develops it kind of
too quickly reaches a position from
normal chess uh but
you you'll see what i mean by this uh so
without further ado let's check it out
as
uh well this is uh quite quite a nail
biter
uh so kasparov with the white pieces
opens with d4 we of course have no
opening
uh and i also have an image of this uh
because
like i said in the previous video uh you
only get three minutes before you see
the position that you're gonna play to
analyze it and then you have to start
playing so here's a nice
image of both gary and magnus analyzing
their positions because part of deep in
focus and magnus having uh
having a nice sip of his water so let's
uh just enjoy that for uh for a brief
moment
and then we continue so d4 by kasparov
uh we have d5 by magnus and now e3 we
have knight f6 knights to f3
e6 and c4 and of course the queen's
gambit the client is on the board i'm
i'm just
joking this is chess 960 but uh it does
appear
uh to be very very similar at uh you
know standard
standard ideas in in normal chess so
here
a6 by magnus uh we have knight to c3 and
now
d captures in c4 with bishop captures
and c5 so
playing like uh it was pretty much
normal chess
uh and here a lot of people were saying
kasparov will just uh move the queen of
course kasparov is not interested in a
queen trade as
uh well because uh carlson is
thought of more of uh something like uh
a positional type player let's say a
carp of 2.0 if you will
uh and kasparov uh uh well he thrives in
really crazy positions where
where a lot of things happen so of
course everyone was considering moves
like this but kasparov played the d
captures in c5 and he offered a queen
trade uh straight from the start uh
magnus uh
pre-moved bishop captures on c5 pretty
sure he did
uh and kasparov traded queens we have
captures and capture so
carlson loses castling privileges but
doesn't really matter queens are off the
board and
the king will be will be very safe in
the center of the board so here
bishop back to d3 fighting for the e4
square
uh and also went to castle maybe you
want to
use the c file for your rook so kink the
e7 by magnus
and now a nice queen side castle by uh
by gary uh for those of you who are new
to chess 960
uh i said in the previous video when you
castle in chess 960 the position of the
king and the rook will be
exactly the same as if you castled in
normal chest so here we castle queen
side
and the king and rook assume uh the same
position like they would in regular
chess
so uh now that the king is on e7 uh
white castle queen side
uh it's pretty much a regular chest
position already as
of move 10. so knight to c6 by magnus
continuing development
uh and now comes knight to g5 because
parov is shifting the attention to this
e4 square
he wants to trade some pieces there and
maybe maybe even get a bishop to this
diagonal
yeah if possible we have rook to d8
magnus continues
developing his pieces and now knight g
to e4 we have knight characters knight
captures uh
and now bishop back to b6 as it's under
attack you could also go bishop to b4
could be very interesting
uh if white trades you get a knight to
this very nice square but magnus prefers
the knight
the bishop on b6 and now bishop on c3
putting pressure uh not there obviously
putting pressure on the g7 pawn
and the magnus plays f6 so is this one
of the positions where it's uh
you know not okay to play f6 uh no
unlikely the queens are off the board
the king is very safe there at some
point you
you will be able to play e5 or f5 so
it's a very flexible position
uh and here kasparov goes for g4
uh it's a very dynamic move in uh well
in somewhat of this
uh somewhat of a steady environment he
wants to play something like rook to g1
play g5 maybe f4 and get something going
on the king side
so he doesn't just move pieces around
with bishop to a5 by magnus
now offering a trade of dark square
bishops because
uh well carlson's dark score bishop
although a very nice piece uh
not really doing all that much whereas
kasparov's dark square bishop
could be his best piece um currently in
the position so of course magnus just uh
trades it up so
knight bishop to a5 and uh
gary trace with bishop captures knight
captures and now
uh the position is around equally
carlson is somewhat better
as uh kasparov still needs to decide
what to do with
with all of those kingside pawns uh and
uh
well uh he's a lower on time
there's some five minute difference uh
kasparov is on seven minutes on the
clock whereas magnus is
on some 12 minutes on the clock so
bishop back to c2 he offers the trade of
rooks and
bishop to c6 now uh the bishop will be
very strong on this diagonal
uh and also just uh putting more defense
to this pawn here if knight ever came to
c5 this would be a weakness
so now you take care of both of these
threats so rook h the g1
kasparov now definitely prepares to push
the pawn to g5
and now knight to c4 so
uh here carlson has some ideas of maybe
shifting the knight over to e5 and then
to f3
and kasparov trades once we have rook
captures on the 8th
rook captures on d8 and now kasparov
pushes g5
so magnus pretty much instantly replied
with f5 he wants to kick away the knight
knight to c3 and here uh carlson took
a few minutes to decide on his next move
whether he wants to
continue expanding on the queen side
where he wants to go knight e5 to f3
or uh possibly bishop to f3 not even
allow kasparov to move this uh pawn from
f2 and it's going to be a very nice
blockade here if rook g5 you can then go
knight to e5
and it's a really uh really tough
position to play really
white would definitely struggle to even
find the move here
however magnus decides to go for knight
to e5 right away
now preparing knight to f3 but now he
allows kasparov to
throw in this f4 idea so f4
knights the f3 attacking the rook and
now rook the g2 kasparov allows some
nasty discoveries
although there aren't uh all that many
of them uh like you could go knight to
e1 with a nice
uh attack on the rook and the bishop but
you don't really care you're
you you enjoy your knight more than uh
kasparov enjoys his bishop here and once
you move the rook there's not
all that much the knight uh the knight
has there
so instead magnus went to g6 he just uh
you know
improves the the position and now rook
f2 because power moves the
moves the rook from any nasty future
discoveries
we have e5 for magnus now preparing e4
and kasparov doesn't want to play a
waiting move like a3 and allow this e4
idea
so he plays a very very tricky idea
which
uh well maybe loses a pawn he plays e4
and now it loses it looks very
reasonable as
your pawn is protected twice so it
shouldn't be a problem however magnus
finds a very nice uh
sequence f captures an e4 knight
captures an e4
and now knight to d4 not allowing
kasparov to to push or capture because
uh here magnus is threatening to remove
the defender of the knight
and then just win a piece so kasparov
needs to move the knight
knight to g3 and now knight captures on
c2
we have king captures and now as uh
well uh you want to prevent kasparov
from pushing or capturing
rook to f8 and now you cannot capture
because it's pinned
uh and of course uh you you cannot push
if you push for example pawn to f5
you're just gonna get g captures on f5
and there's uh
nothing for you to do because after
knight captures or rook captures for
that matter doesn't really matter
captures captures and bishop to e4 check
uh this is what magnus had in mind and
why the the the idea is so strong
the king would have to move you're gonna
capture and of course win the game
so after this uh uh rook to f8 uh
you have to decide what to do you cannot
advance the pawn you cannot capture
because the rook falls
so what you could do is go for knight to
e2 a very ugly looking move
very passively defending uh this f4 pawn
or you could try rook to e2 because
sparrow took some time and really
thought
things through here and he didn't like
rookie two because after
you give up the pawn and you win back
the pawn
you're still not going to be able to
keep it because king d6 you have to move
back with the rook and then
rook g4 the g5 pawn will fall and then
carlson's king side pawns start marching
down the board
so here after rook to f8 kasparov played
the well the ugly looking knight to e2
uh and now uh well now it's uh carlson
to move
king to e6 he's in no rush to do
anything here
uh he just improves the position of his
king kasparov still has to deal with
this pin so king to d2
and now bishop to b5 and now carlson is
just preparing to remove
the defender of the f4 pawn and win the
pawn and hopefully the game
so casparo played rook to f3 and when
caspar played rook to f3
crossing went into a really deep thing
he thought for some five minutes here
uh because well it looks like you can
just win a pawn
uh by capturing the knight and then
picking up the pawn but
uh and while in fact you can this is
probably what carlson saw
bishop captures on e2 king captures pawn
captures
and now as kasparov made this rook lift
to rook to f3 rook to b3
going after the pawn and now carlson
thought okay rook f7 defends the pawn
and then i can move my king to f5 to g4
and i mean it's probably or or here and
capture this pawn and then just win the
game
however after thinking for five minutes
magnus played
rook to f7 and it does make sense and he
he
he took all of this into consideration
he said okay now this pawn will already
be defended
i mean no rush to capture i'm gonna
capture here next and then gonna win the
pawn but he missed one move from
kasparov rook to e3
and now there's a problem you can no
longer capture with the pawn and of
course
you cannot capture with the rogue
because now just the the rook captures
so magnus played bishop captures an e2
hoping to grab the pawn on the next move
but now kasparov has the very simple
rook captures on e5 with check king d6
and now
rook captures on e2 and now uh it's
kasparov who's up upon of course magnus
wins it back right away rook captures on
f4
and now it's a a rook end game with four
pawns each and kasparov
already plays the very interesting king
to e3
now rook to e3 is a is a safer way to go
if you want to defend everything for
example if rook g4
then you can go a rook to h3 and now
it's a it's a draw captures capture so
now with only
one pawn each on the king side there
it's a very easy draw
also after rook to e3 instead of rook g4
if magnus goes for rook to f2 which is
better
then you'd go rookie 2 rook f5 magnus
goes after the pawn you defend it
and after this rook f4 rook to h2 a very
passive rook for kasparov but
you know you defend for the moment this
would uh this would be best for
for magnus however after this king to e3
idea
by kasparov uh magnus plays rook to g4
right away
goes after the pawn and now rook to d to
check king e6
and now rook to c2 you could try to go
for some tricks with rook to e2
with the idea that if captures uh check
with an attack on the rook but
magnus defends with king f6 so it's not
a problem so after this king e6 with
king to c2
now kasparov wants to go after uh the
the seventh rank he wants to promote his
rook to a pig
uh and magnus says okay rook captures on
g5 we
rook the c7 and now rook the b5
uh from uh from agnes and here the
situation on the clock is one minute
kasparov
three minutes for carlson uh uh here
rook to b5 to defend the pawn and go
after this one
also possible was rook to g2 to just go
after these two pawns magnus likes rook
to b5
and now kasparov goes for rook captures
on h7 he allows this trade
rook captures on b2 and now a4
so here magnus is now up upon and
it's going to be is going to be hard for
kasparov to hold this with
a5 by kasparov and now uh
kasparov needs to go uh in with the king
king f4
needs to be played and then after let's
say rook before check king b5
you would see a trait here captures
captures and now it's a draw you're
going to eliminate this pawn and it's
not
not a big deal okay one king captures
here and one pass pawn each
on the side of the board it's a complete
draw
however kasparov started with h4 and now
the position is actually winning for
magnus
so feel free to pause the video and win
the game for magnus
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on being a true
master of the endgame
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's rook b4
uh cutting the king off and just going
after this pawn
and now it's very very hard for kasparov
we have
rook to h6 but now it's not it's not
that simple the position is winning
however uh
with little time on the clock you have
to be able to play the absolute precise
move
uh and here the only winning move for
carlson is king to d7 and magnus missed
this move the idea behind king to d7 is
uh after kasparov captures on g6 and you
capture on h4 the point is after rook g7
check you will be in time to
defend uh your b7 pawn you're going to
pick up this one
and you will have two connected pawns on
the queen side of course in a in a
completely winning end game
however magnus played king to f7 seems
even better
as i mean you you're defending this guy
here and
if if rook to h7 checked this rook is
already guarding the pawn it's not a
problem
however now it's kasparov to move and
draw the game there's only one move that
helps kasparov out so once again feel
free to pause the video
and don't lose the game for gary while i
give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on being an
excellent avoider of losses and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show
it's h5 and this uh settles
settles the game uh here carlson has the
capture because now kasparov is also
threatening to create a pass pawn either
with captures or with captures
so magnus captured but now rook captures
an h5 and now there's a problem this
pawn is hanging
point being that if magnus captures this
bond then rook b5
goes after this pawn and if you defend
then just rook capture sun b4 and
this is a well-known draw you will not
be able to win this game being up just
one pawn
so here after rook to h5 b6 magnus
defends this and now comes
rook to e5 cutting off the black king
from entering the game
uh if captures then the same same idea
applies so king f6
we have rook to e4 of course because
power knows that the rook trade is a
draw because his king is much faster
so rugby three check and now king to d2
now we have king f5 and now rook to h4
again cutting the black king off king e5
and now king to c2
we have rook to f3 and now rook to h6
going after the pawn here
rook to f6 defending and now of course
kasparov
without much thinking just trades and
goes into a kingdom pawn
end game king to d3 king to e5 and now
even king to e3
uh not even not even rushing with king
to c4 so he shows that
of course this is a complete draw plays
king e3 king d6 by magnus king d4 we
have king to c6 and king to c4 and there
is no way to make progress for magnus
he just pushed b5 here delivered to
check and it was
in this position on move 55 that the two
of them agreed to a draw
as there is nothing more to be done here
for black to push for a win because
after captures with
check king b6 king b3 and captures white
king will just hide in
in the corner and of course the black
king will not have anything to do about
it
so yeah b5 check they agreed to a draw
and after 16 years uh
carlson is yet to uh
find his victory and uh well this this
was a great opportunity because sparrow
doesn't uh come out of uh
retirement very often he he does like
once a year to play some funky
tournaments like chess 960 and stuff
but this is the first time that he faced
carlson and it's
uh well it's uh it's a question when
when carlson will get
another chance to grab at least one
victory against former world champion
gary kasparov
so very interesting kasparov with a win
in round one against ferruja and then a
draw against magnus uh in the in the
second round uh in the previous video i
told you that it was a double round
robin it's actually not it's a single
round robin so
this is the only game two of them will
play in this tournament and who knows
when they will face each other again
but yeah great start for casparo we'll
see we'll see what happens and
well we'll just continue continue
enjoying the show
so once again i do hope you guys enjoyed
it i would like to thank you george
stanislaw cooperstein uh james patrick
washington
and the chest with trisha for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching
and i will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the champions showdown
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
see you soon